esta vez nos piden que ordenemos las
siguientes medidas de la más grande a la
más pequeña y tenemos 2.1 litros 3
litros y 32 mil mililitros ok si yo
quiero ordenar estas medidas ya sea de
la más grande a la más pequeña de la más
pequeña a la más grande no importa si lo
que buscamos es ordenarla pues hay que
ponerla en la misma medida y en este
caso litros me pareció una buena opción
vamos entonces a copiar esta información
ya colocarla en un espacio en el que
podamos trabajar
perfecto aquí tenemos la misma
información y lo que haremos es
convertir estos datos en litros
tenemos aquí litros y litros digamos que
está bastante sencillo sin embargo
tenemos mililitros y para que nosotros
recordemos pues vamos a hacer lo
siguiente
tenemos litros
como unidad básica
porque esta será nuestra unidad 1 litro
cuando tenemos beca
eso significa que tendremos 10
de esas unidades en este caso de cal y
tros y qué tal con metros de cametro si
no seguimos hacia 100
tendremos esto
estos litros hectómetros si nos vamos a
mil
tendremos kilo
kilolitros
kilómetros kilogramos incluso ya los
conocen ahora si nos vamos hacia los
números que son menores a un litro
tendremos
un décimo que lo llamaremos de sí
decímetros decilitro el siguiente
prefijo
un centésimo serás en ti
centilitros centímetros
y finalmente si hacemos
el correspondiente a una milésima parte
de un litro será 1000
mililitro
milímetros miligramos ok entonces ya que
tenemos esta información podemos
saber cómo convertir estas unidades
tenemos 2.1 litros que ya está en litros
tenemos 3 litros que ya se encuentra en
la unidad que es litros pero tenemos 32
mil mililitros podemos escribir estos 32
mil mililitros lo cual equivale a 32 mil
por mil y será una milésima parte
de litro estamos de acuerdo
al multiplicar
32.000 por una milésima parte de litro
tendremos entonces 32
por lo tanto si nosotros acomodamos de
la más grande a la más pequeña tendremos
primero 32 litros
luego tendremos 3 litros
y finalmente tendremos
2.1 litros
vamos a reescribir lo en el ejercicio y
veamos si nuestra respuesta es correcta
ok estamos de regreso a nuestro
ejercicio para recordar tendremos
entonces que el más grande fue 32
mililitros podemos moverlos para
acomodar los 3 litros y 2.1 litros
veamos si esta respuesta es correcta
y es correcta